bugging me for about 25 years I think
that's why I became president you want
to know that truth what we've done with
your great deal of the u.s. MCA and
Canada no longer takes advantage of us
like they did people don't realize Oh
Canada beautiful national anthem right
Oh Canada but they were brutal on trade
and now they have to treat us fairly US
MCA we got rid of the worst trade deal
ever made in the history of mankind
humankind you know I think that like we
say nowadays humankind right human can't
see the ladies I think they like it the
other way just as much humankind but I
just want to say that we have an
incredible deal it's gonna lead to a lot
of a lot of very positive things but the
west of Wisconsin supply chain 9,000
more jobs are going to be generated
because of the chain itself and it's a
truly phenomenal achievement and I
congratulate you all it's gonna be an
incredible thing it's all gonna be made
right here in Wisconsin under this
administration you though that American
workers like you are a national treasure
you are indeed victory at sea you know
victory at sea that's what you lead us
to your patriotism cannot be outsourced
you're eight decades of industrial
heritage cannot be replicated anywhere
in the world that's why we're protecting
our defense and our defensive industrial
base which we're building up stronger
and stronger and stronger and we have
other places all over the country just
like this well let's say this is better
ok but that's ok just don't tell anybody
I said it but we have places great
places credible people tremendously
tremendously successful people people
with tremendous talent and we're doing
other things in other locations like the
missiles like the Rockets like the tanks
like all of the things that we're
building it's incredible when you see it
it's incredible people don't realize the
talent that we have for we started
getting away from it we started not
building in the Navy we haven't built
enough ships the ships that they were
building they look terrible I've changed
designs I looked at it
said that's a terrible looking ship
let's make it beautiful it'll cost you
the same and maybe less you know
sometimes you can make it look great for
less money I said this is not a good
looking ship let's change the design of
it and I got people in and we looked at
different designs and as long as we're
gonna do it and look at what you're
doing how beautiful it is they gave me a
beautiful model that's absolutely it's
it's like a yacht with missiles on okay
it's like beautiful but you know it's
true you can build beautifully and it
course you sometimes less money
sometimes less money so that's why we're
protecting our defensive industrial base
and restoring this fundamental principle
and that's economic security is national
security that's what it is because you
know what you were going through in this
area of Wisconsin just a short period of
time ago and it wasn't right and it
wasn't fair as long as I'm your
president America will never lose that
ship building talent or capability it
won't lose that excellence or the
expertise of the men and the women of
Marinette Marine will never lose that
never lose it and will always live by
two simple rules by American and higher
American by America the first in class F
F G X will not just be a win for
Wisconsin workers it will also be a
major victory for our Navy and our Navy
is just incredible what we're doing with
our Navy the stunning ships will deliver
the overwhelming force lethality and
power we need to engage America's
enemies anywhere and at any time and
with that we don't want to engage but
you know how you don't have to engage
when you build a product like you're
building right there when you build
product like that you don't have to when
you don't build product like that and we
go there you know we rebuilt our
military our military was totally
depleted when I became your president we
had planes that were 50 years old we had
a military that was tired
very tired from years of fighting
endless wars Wars it never stopped then
you see what's happening in that front
we have the strongest military in the
world by far and before we had an old we
had a very tired
military what we had who were great
people in the military but they weren't
given the right equipment so now they
are two and a half trillion dollars each
frigate will boast a thirty two cell
vertical missile launcher to take
American justice to any foe if necessary
or in air land or sea you know about it
very well you live with it
the ship will feel the most advanced air
research and air search radar capability
in naval history there has never been
anything so advanced as what you're
building is the ship is thirty times
more powerful than the previous
generation that was one that got me
thirty times think of that thirty times
more powerful than the previous
generation and it will carry an mh-60
Seahawk helicopter and an unmanned mqh
see fire scout drone through your sweat
skill and devotion the workers of this
shipyard will forge the future of the
United States Navy you're gonna be a
very big part of the United States Navy
and there are other things coming as you
get set up with this this is a lot to
handle but as you get set up they're
going to be spending a lot of money on
the renovation of the yard and the
expansion of the earth we have other
things coming and you'll fashion the
ultimate symbol of American power and
American prestige wherever the FF GX
cuts across the horizon it will go as a
7,500 ton message to the world that
American might is second to none
right I'd like to take a moment to
recognize just a few of the hard-working
Patriots who are helping to bring these
monumental ships to life and that's what
they are
Gary Ayad is the third generation of his
family to serve at this shipyard
he has worked here for 17 years and is
now our production manager Gary please
come up and say a few words Gary thank
you Thank You mr. president
it is honor to meet you my name is Gary
I am a production manager here at
fincantieri Marinette Marine
I work in building 10 I want you just
toward the erections of facility I've
been fortunate to be employed here for
over 17 years I started in the trades
and through hard work and dedication I
transitioned into management these
employees in front of you are here to
build the best ships possible this pride
felt when a ship gets launched or goes
out on trials is like nothing else
these men and women breathe life into
steel through hard work long hours and
dedications these individuals give the
American warfighter the ship he or she
needs and deserves mr. president
Wisconsin thanks you the city of
Marinette thanks you and Fincantieri
Marinette Marine thanks
[Applause]
it looks like he's 21 years old he said
he worked here a long time Gary whatever
you're doing it's working you look good
we're also joined by Tyler Cahill Tyler
served for nine years of the US Navy
then returned here to his hometown to
become a quality Technical Coordinator
Tyler also helps recruit young talented
people usually I guess from Wisconsin I
think probably I don't know if he
accepts anybody from anywhere else you
have to talk about that I think but I
want to just ask Tyler please come up
and say a few words
thank you thank you good afternoon
everyone my name is Tyler Cahill
I'm the native to the Marinette area a
former second class petty officer in the
United States Navy Seabees an
Afghanistan war vet a hockey coach an
equality coordinator here at Marinette
Marine when I first moved back to
Marinette and started here as a welder
in 2012 what an ever I'll imagine how
far my career the community would grow
the shipyard is a lifeline to the
community and a driving force behind its
economic growth in major part due to the
LCS program and the newly awarded
frigate contract I've seen young
families moved to the area friends open
new local businesses and a beautiful new
sports facility open to be utilized by
the local hockey kids that I get to
coach this would have been possible
without these contracts so once again
mr. president I'd like to say thank you
and allowing us to continue supporting
our nation's Navy thank you Thank You
Tyler looks like a tough hockey player I
wouldn't want to be checking him right
it's a pretty tough looking guy the
dedication of the men and women here
today will also help our military
accomplished one of my top national
security priorities rebuilding a 355
ship Navy as I told you
it went way down first said after years
of painful budget cuts we ended the last
administration's disastrous defense
sequester we ended the sequester you
know what that means I think most of you
let's put it that way or this way it was
a very good thing that we that we did
otherwise you wouldn't be building these
ships right now we ended what was a true
disaster we've invested the 2.5 trillion
dollars in all of the greatest equipment
in the world and it's all made here
right in the USA and a lot of it is
going to be made in Wisconsin outside of
this facility also and I signed a new
law creating very importantly this was
something very important to me the sixth
branch of the US military the space
force that's a big deal that's a big
deal we're revitalizing our partnerships
around the world and insisting that
other nations pay their fair share in
NATO they weren't paying up and now many
of them are some of them don't pay like
they should that delinquent you know
that word that delinquent
no other president pressed them to pay I
press them to pay and the people at NATO
are very happy with me I will tell you
the secretary-general said there's never
been anything like it we took in a
hundred and forty billion dollars more
money from other people not from us from
other people paying their bills because
for many years they didn't pay their
bills we were guarding nations and they
weren't paying for it and somehow I said
that doesn't work too well not for me
and not for you either because you're
smart this is great news for American
workers and taxpayers as part of Saudi
Arabia's effort to fulfill its own
defence obligations
last year the Kingdom placed a 1.3
billion dollar order for four new
vessels made by your great company so
you know the vessels they're getting
built right now and we felt very
strongly that this is where it should be
and we gave them a strong recommendation
and they followed it that's very good
since 1942 when your company was founded
to build five wooden barges for world
war ii this small town in Wisconsin is
raised up one of the premier
shipbuilding enterprises anywhere on
earth and have you come back here in
five years you'll see one of the top
places anywhere in the world
you should take immense pride in what
you've done and those before you in many
cases your father's and your
grandfather's in many cases your
father's are alive and very proud of the
job you're doing I met three people
whose fathers worked here and it looked
like it was ending and now they work
here and they're gonna be here for a
long time and I said get your son ready
or get your daughter ready your
tradition of excellence has given
America two classes of combat ships the
Coast Guard cutters that patrol our
maritime borders a state-of-the-art
icebreaker which is incredible which we
had not an easy time getting approved I
will tell you that Democrats don't like
approving money for the military for
whatever reason some day you'll explain
that to me they don't like spending
money on our military several of the
Staten Island ferries and so much more
doing a lot of work the workers of the
shipyard and the people of this state
have always prospered and persevered by
holding fast to our shared American
values in this country we are on a work
we celebrate great craftsmanship I
understand craftsmanship I understand
this world so well you wouldn't believe
it you wouldn't believe it how well I
understand it and how well I appreciate
it I appreciate talent and that's real
talent craftsmanship and we salute the
dignity and nobility of the American
worker we look out for one that you
wouldn't believe we look out for
everybody we look out for one another
we're loyal to one another and we love
our families we want our families taken
care of we want our families to prosper
we want our community to prosper this
community was not prospering with all
that talent they weren't prospering and
now you're all working and doing
something that you love you can't wait I
know most of you you can't wait to get
to work that's the way I feel and your
job is much more pleasant than mine that
I can guarantee that I can
oh you don't know what I have to go
through with these people they said to
me sir a friend of mine very smart very
successful person used to call me Donald
now he calls me sir since mr. president
I said call me Donald yes but I can't
mr. president
which is okay he said so which is the
toughest nation to deal with is it China
is it possibly Russia or is it maybe
North Korea I said no the toughest
nation to deal with are the Democrats in
the USA Democrats in the USA are much
tougher to deal with any of these people
that we deal with they're far more
unreasonable and actually they're a
little crazy we take care of our
communities and when the time comes when
history calls when our flag is
threatened we defend our country like
nobody else has ever defended our
country or our flag we defend our flag
[Music]
we stand tall we stand strong and we
always stand proud of the United States
of America with the help of everyone
here today this shipyard will continue
to prosper this state will continue to
thrive and this nation that we love will
climb to new heights of glory and to
greatness and that's what's happening
right now we're going to have a great
third quarter and we're going to have a
phenomenal next year you'll see next
year will be one of the greatest years
you see it happening already it's
happening and it's happening quickly so
I want to thank everybody at this
amazing yard I want to thank the
grandparents and the parents who put you
here they're very proud of you some are
looking down on you right now they're
looking down from heaven and they're
very proud of you they're very very
proud and I'm also very proud of you so
congratulations see you all god bless
you and God bless america thank you all
thank you
thank you thank you
[Applause]
[Music]